now the Prime Minister says he's going
to be laying out a plan this week to
explain how we can get our economy
moving again so should we expect to see
some of the lockdown measures eased
we'll have to wait to see what he says
but I don't think we should expect us to
go from you know this situation that we
have at the moment of social distancing
to back to where we were in February
that's clearly not going to happen I
don't think anyone imagines that for one
moment the most important thing is I
think is that the absolute sort of focus
of what the prime minister will be
announcing later in the week is that
what we do do going forward doesn't undo
the brilliant work people have been
doing to get that as you mentioned the
are number below one the all the
critical reproduction rate doesn't come
back up because that's when we'd see a
second spike so I know I'm afraid it's
not definitely not going to be you know
businesses as usual but we do want to
make sure that the people understand
where the route map lies yeah I don't
think anyone would be expecting business
as usual but as you say that kind desire
to see a bit of the route map is
something that many people will feel
quite strongly there are reports today
that primary schools could be one of the
things that the government is
prioritizing the date of June has been
thrown around I know you of course you
won't want to be drawn on when any of
these measures could happen that's I'm
sure very much still something that's up
for debate but could you confirm that
getting primary schools back is
something that the government is
prioritizing look what I mean of course
we want the economy to work again we
want schools to work again we want
people to be able to go back to to work
and businesses to open all of those
things but it's also the case that we're
still working with teachers and case of
schools teachers and parents and schools
themselves as well as you know the
scientists to work out what and when
would be safe so you know to answer your
question straight of course is huge
desire to get everything back to normal
but we have to make sure that we've
satisfied those key five tests that we
set out of which the most important new
recall was that we don't spark a a
second wave by not keeping the the our
number under control
that means thinking about how we look at
social distancing in this world going
forward and testing tracking and tracing
all of those things are going to be
absolutely vital going forward and
that's why there's so much work going on
in parallel to the decisions coming
forward from the or the recommendations
coming forward and then later this week
the roadmap coming forth from the prime
minister to make sure that test track
and trace is in place I mean you say
though that there's a disaster get
everything back to normal of course I'm
sure that is the case but I mean is
there any specific desire to get younger
children in particular back into
education well it look getting schools
going again is one of the considerations
obviously my particular area transport
and how we get that working again is
another one and it is the case that the
business secretary has been working with
various different elements of you know
business industrial and different types
categories of business organizations to
work up what the plans might look like
so you know it's no secret that of
course we won't be kids to be able to go
back to school but I'd be over egging it
to say there's a date in place there's a
plan in place you will have to wait till
later in this week to hear more detail
from the prime minister on all of these
fronts but I don't want people to be
watching this this morning thinking ah
but that's it the most important thing
we do is to carry on following the rules
for the time being and the Prime
Minister will set out the path going
forward when he speaks about this at the
back end of the week you mentioned your
own brief their air transport and the
Prime Minister does say that his plan
will include measures about how we can
travel to work safely and so what kind
of thing could we see on buses and
trains lots of people will be worried
about using public transport
but anything's very important to be able
to reassure people when we do get back
to people using the public transport
more at the moment of course usage is
very small perhaps 5% of its its usual
level but I've spoken before about
things like you know staggering work
times obviously very important to avoid
those those morning peaks and the
crushes would be completely at odds with
social distancing of course I'm very
concerned about people being able to
wash their hands it's still the by far
in a way the most important advice above
anything else that even above face masks
and all the rest of it is basic hygiene
the hand-washing that message from right
at the beginning well we can help with
that by trying to have hand sanitizer
one-way systems and spacing on platforms
and at bus stops and that sort of thing
clearly marked out so there are a lot of
different measures that that can be
taken of which easing into this is going
to clearly be one of the most important
things of all I mean could we see
measures like people being temperature
checks before using public transport or
perhaps a limit on the number of people
who could get on at one time I mean it
is the case and I should just remind
everybody about this I saw that story
the last day or two it is the case and
remains the case that if you feel unwell
if you've got a temperature you
shouldn't be leaving home because that
could be coronavirus you shouldn't be
leaving home let alone going and getting
on on public transport and that remains
the case because the big difference now
is because we've got this big test
capacity is you can go to govern UK and
if you are a key worker and increasingly
many other categories coming into this
then you can just order a test I've been
on this site this morning I noticed
Emperor checks on that could we see
temperature checks then on public
transport well my point is people
shouldn't be leaving home if they're not
if not feeling well and the thing about
coronaviruses a sort of temperature that
you feel the way that you feel is
absolutely critical to that so you you
in a sense you you shouldn't be there in
the first place some people may that's
the point
yes it's possible but you know when you
when you think about this it reminds me
of a question I was asked the the other
day when we were talking
the problems of people obtaining tests
and needles go on the site and perhaps
being a key worker and not being able to
get on the site till late today to order
a test and as as the Jenny Harry's the
one of the scientific officers points
that you people shouldn't be going to
work if they feel that way and the same
with Transport they shouldn't be going
to work you shouldn't be going to work
if you feel unwell of course right now
the only people who should be going to
work people who cannot work from home
and key workers and that remains the
case so it's a bit of a sort of moot
point
really about temperature checking on
Transport please don't leave the house
if you have a temperature okay and you
talk there about the importance of and
socially distancing on public transport
I just wonder do you think there'll be a
point when you might have to increase
the number of services available in a
minute for example most part of the rail
work currently operating on a half
timetable yeah that is right and you
know I'm working very closely with the
rail sector for example to make sure
that we ordinarily in May famously in
fact there are normally new timetables
and so we'll still proceed with putting
a new timetable into place and but
clearly we won't be running anywhere
near the full number of trains but it is
the case as you point out that gradually
we will want to increase the amount of
trains available because preventing that
overcrowding which is going to be a huge
logistical task and will require the
same sort of determination that British
people have shown and you know respect
and social distancing by following the
rules and staying at home we'll need
that to happen and work with companies
and individuals to make sure that
happens on our transport system as well
it's so important that we don't lose the
gains that we have made in bringing the
are number we think down now somewhere
between not 0.6 and 0.85 something like
that and so less than one remember means
it's not spreading to more and more
people it stops us from getting back
onto a curve going upwards and that's so
important and public transport is gonna
be a vital part of that one thing I
should mention it's a massive increase
in active transport in cycling and we've
seen hundreds of percent increase in a
very popular scheme which means you can
you can buy a bike through your employer
effectively before tax and pay it back
through a loan those are popular schemes
there always have been but we've seen
hundreds of percent increase in that
scheme and I'm going to be saying more
about that shortly because active
transport keeping people off the public
transport and getting there under their
own steam getting to work under an steam
that could be a very important part of
this recovery as well now another part
of your brief of course transport will
be about whether or not to impose more
restrictions on people entering the
United Kingdom at ports or airports for
example now some people will be
wondering why it is that we haven't done
that already I mean South Korea for
example introduced restrictions from
early February now test everyone who
arrives you have to quarantine for two
weeks they've had 250 deaths Singapore
restricted some flights from China back
in January they've only had 17 deaths
why haven't we done this already and are
we gonna be changing that in the future
so the first thing says we have millions
of British nationals to bring back home
literally people away in March on
average three million Brits would go
abroad and many of those had to be
returned home and that process has just
been continuing for a while the second
thing is that once it's prevalent within
your own society that the scientists the
medical experts tell us there's actually
precious little point if it's already
within your existing community out of
this well as I say there are millions of
Brits to get home is the first thing you
can still quarantine them they can
follow up medical advice sorry I missed
that
you can still quarantine them down get
them home right and the rules exist so
that everybody in this country has to be
at home right now in fact it's illegal
not to be it to be outside the home your
home for one of any other than for
reasons as we know so I mean that
remains the case for everyone but going
forward as the number of cases comes
down and therefore the people coming in
becomes much more significant the other
thing to say is very few people actually
traveling of course but as people come
in becomes more significant once we have
as we're seeing now a decline in the
cases then then I think it does become
very much more critical to the overall
numbers and that's why we are actively
working on the measures going forward
and we'll say more about those in time
okay what kind of thing could we see
them well exactly as he suggests it you
know I think it would be wrong for
example if we're still all being asked
to socially distance for people coming
in not to do the same thing so we've
been looking at things like this app
that very soon in two or three weeks
time we're going to be asking the whole
country to download which will help with
the test and track and trace and this is
obviously the tracking part of it that's
very important and we could be for
example asking everybody who comes here
to require to have that happen the same
rules apply to anyone visiting which is
as you know to stay locked down
affectively and that should say the same
social distance rules clearly would need
to apply to everybody under those
circumstances you mentioned that app and
of course that's clearly going to be a
big part of the government strategy
going forward as we try to ease the
lockdown and keep the are number and the
infection rate number down and when does
that system going to be up and running
right so that systems going into testing
this week on the Isle of Wight and then
later in the month that app will be
rolled out and deployed assuming the
tests are successful of course to the
population at large and the idea is that
we will encourage as many people to take
this up as possible there's gonna be a
huge national effort we need for this to
work 50 60 % of people to be using this
app not everybody has a smartphone I
appreciate them for various reasons not
everybody will download it but it will
be the best possible way to help the NHS
in fact it will be an NHS app it will be
completely confidential the information
doesn't stay on there you don't know who
the individuals are but what it would do
is alert people if they've been near
somebody who later is diagnosed as
having coronavirus this is a fantastic
automated part of the of the tracking
part of the puzzle and now we have the
testing capacity of over a hundred
thousand tests as you mentioned that
will continue to rise and this is a
fantastic way to
ensure that we are able to really keep a
lid on this going forward and we don't
get that second wave so I think it's one
of the most exciting developments and I
think you know on a Thursday night when
people are going out and clapping in
future the ability to do something else
of use which will be to download that
app in the future will be a great way to
support the NHS just quickly before we
move on to other things how many of the
18,000 contract racers have been hard so
far I don't know the answer to that but
that's actually I think a fairly
straightforward and this is not
something which requires why don't we
know the are these weeks or months of
training it's not my particular area of
policy that's all but it's not it's not
an issue because the app isn't going to
be available for some time yet a few
weeks yet but when it is there we will
have the people in place it's not yeah I
don't want to get into another so we had
this with a hundred thousand tests so I
realize and as you saw we ended up
meeting and exceeding the the numbers
will have the 18,000 contact traces in
in place it's not a particularly
complicated thing to do and as you've
seen people are more than willing to
come forward and be incredibly public
spirit okay when it comes to defeating
this as a nation
okay now the Prime Minister said on
Thursday and the objective of this
government is to save lives that's been
our objective from the beginning but
more than 28,000 people have now died
after testing positive for cocaine in
the United Kingdom only the US and Italy
have seen more deaths I mean the
government's own graph that you've been
showing at these press conferences it
shows that we're on track to actually
overtake Italy as well by your own
metric haven't you failed no I don't
agree with that I mean first thing to
say is that everybody every death has
been a absolute tragedy I know quite a
number of people who've been affected by
this disease as virtually everybody will
know people now but I don't agree with
that for a whole variety of reasons we
need to be very very careful at the way
we assess this information as Professor
David Spiegel haltere pointed out in The
Guardian this week simply looking at
that raw data doesn't actually tell you
the story what you need to look at is
excess mortalities okay that's a time
let's look at the excess mortality in
that case then because actually say
Chris witty as well the chief medical
officer says that's the best way perhaps
to look at it but when you look at
excess deaths that the number of deaths
per week above the normal average you
can see that other countries had a spike
but have fallen but England's line is
far higher and still rising so even if
you look at the excess mortality data
the government has still failed to keep
the deaths down the Chris witty and
others would make is actually you need
to look at that over a much longer
period of time so I'd have to look back
over a year and afraid not to be evasive
we just won't have that information but
we only had the data available at the
minute and the available data shows that
the government has not been keeping the
deaths down in the same way that other
cuts some other countries have so as I
say and it is much more complex than
you're making it sound for the simple
reason that there are other factors
taken to account on excess mortalities
which we won't know about today for
example what does it do you know in
terms of other illnesses and diseases
and what was the you know what was the
impact of for example the fact that we
were able unlike in many other countries
Italy being an example and who have a
first-class usually a first-class health
system but have found their hospitals
completely over loaded whereas we've
managed maintain critical care space
against what everyone thought was likely
at the beginning and ventilators and all
the rest of it so you have to look at
the whole picture and that information
simply isn't available as yet but as
scientists point out there will be a
whole range of things that need to be
looked at obviously the demographics of
the country age profiles things like
obesity we know that people in different
health categories with underlying
problems fare differently in different
countries have different levels of these
sort of things
geography density of cities like London
for example so there's a huge amount of
different things to look at and and I
just caution as the medical experts do
that we shouldn't look at the raw data
and jump to conclusions on this because
actually the NHS has been doing a
terrific job and there will be other
deaths outside of coronavirus that may
or may not have happened had it been
handled differently without
example sufficient hospital capacity and
another area where we've seen sadly a
lot of deaths as in care homes as well
just finally and we've heard stories
about care staff not getting sufficient
protective equipment it was only two and
a half weeks ago the government said it
would start testing everyone in care
homes that had symptoms
we've also even seen cases of people
being moved from hospitals to care homes
with kovat 19 so why did it take until
mid-april to start testing people being
discharged from hospitals into care
homes and have people in care homes been
abandoned first of all I don't think
there's any you know absolutely straight
with people that in terms of getting
enough PPE it has been enormous ly
challenging the whole world is after
this protective equipment we've managed
to having said that and deliver well
over a billion pieces now millions more
and every single day including two care
homes where it is now not only possible
to be tested if you are symptomatic but
a symptomatic care home both patients
and carers can now be routinely tested
so there been massive improvements but I
don't think you know this is not unique
to us I saw doctors care home workers
holding a protest outside the German
Bundestag for exactly the same reason in
Germany a country often held up as doing
well so this is just a massive issue of
which British companies have come
forward in extraordinary numbers over
ten and a half thousand companies have
come forward to offer help with PPE and
we are doing everything we possibly can
pull Dayton the the guy who ran the
Olympics so successfully in this country
now in charge of getting all of that
distributed to the right places and so
on and so forth but I don't want you
there is no other way to say this is not
an easy task to get that level of PPE to
the right places but it is flowing now
and both for residents and for people
we're working in care homes and you know
we my heart goes out and again I know
people in this situation where lives
have been lost in in care homes or in
the community in general or or in
hospital this is at
robell disease and we are all fighting
it just as hard as we can okay grant
chaps thank you very much for coming on
the program and talking through the
government's response thank you very
much thank you